are we ready for season five of
Yellowstone because after that trailer I
don't know if my motions can handle it
uh it's gonna be fun it's gonna be a bit
it's gonna be a really exciting
opportunity for all the fans
um here's the thing this is what I'll
say this season is a big season of
change there's a lot of different
elements that are moving around and
obviously as everyone knows John Dutton
is now the governor of Montana and so
because of that he's going to spend a
lot of time outside of the ranch which
will also leave a lot of opportunities
for the people that don't like us very
much too
um take advantage of that um so I think
that this is going to be for every
single character this is definitely the
theme of this year is definitely
um a season of change so we're excited
to see what the audience uh what they
make of that
are you saying that the bunkhouse boys
are basically going to be taking
advantage of the fact that John dutton's
away from the ranch
we we probably make one or two mistakes
uh that we probably wouldn't be making
uh if we had a little bit more oversight
uh but you know our heart is always in
the right place uh but we are also you
know we're grown so we're also willing
to uh to be held accountable
playing Colby this season in particular
yeah you know this was great um this was
a you know last year we took the year
off because they were doing another show
they were doing um 1883.
um and so we kind of had a year off from
the season four to the season five and
so this year was kind of very special
because it had been the longest in the
last like four years that we had all
kind of been separated so to kind of see
everybody come back and you know it felt
like we literally hadn't missed a day
um but you know we all kind of are in
different text messages chains and stuff
like that but this year was just so fun
because we're doing so much more
cowboying which I know for people that
are hearing that they're like how could
you do even more than you guys have
already been doing but as the season
goes on Taylor writes just more
phenomenal opportunities for us uh so
this year I think we really got to just
sit in the full Cowboy experience uh
which is again like I said very very odd
considering the fact that we are on a
western show but this year I think
everyone will really see like dang we
didn't know that they could do all this
so I think that's something that Colby
uh really got to experience this year as
well as well well as denim who gets to
uh have lived that life of Colby that's
so cool I love hearing that you know I
gotta ask about Colby and Teeter
a little bit more love connection going
on this season we miss it you know we
want more yeah there's gonna be there's
gonna be some you know somebody people
ask us all the time like what is our
relationship
um and the reality of it is we trauma
bonded right uh and she you know she got
what she wanted and I think that she's
slowly as the season kind of goes
forward I think you're gonna start to
see the ice melt with Colby
she's just she wears you down and uh at
a certain point uh I think you'll you'll
see the that kind of love uh this is the
first year I will say this as a little
spoiler this is the first year that
Colby gets her a gift
um and I think that's something that is
going to be uh yeah it's something sweet
uh for Colby that's his love language
apparently he's uh uh gifts I love that
do you denim think it's a cute gift or
is this just a gift Colby thinks is cute
yeah like I think when I would you know
yeah I think it's fine I mean I don't
know the denim himself would would think
doing this but you know it's his own
little way it's his Cowboy Way you know
we're a little bit Kobe's very chill you
know so but I think that everybody is
going to at least see that Kobe is doing
the best that he can to speak his love
language Kobe doesn't know a lot about
Love Languages but I think that uh he's
learning through Teeter
um how to start sharing that a little
bit more oh I love that we spoke to Jen
a couple of months ago and she said if
there's this strong connection this
season uh that it would be done in a
refreshing way do you agree with that
yes I think you know the great thing
about you know and obviously gen land is
so phenomenal uh with theater and she
makes it just so much fun to play
um but yeah I think the great thing is
like we we really live in the kind of
the world of trying to be organic you
know the Colby and Teeter Don't Force
anything uh but they also take the
opportunities that you know Teeter is
very very observant to the things that
that go on
um and Kobe in his own way looks after
her um you know so this season there's
you know a lot of different fights we
have some of the the craziest uh
situations that happened this year that
Colby kind of gets thrust into because
Teeter is a little bit wild
um and so I think that there's a lot of
this kind of organic nature because as
everybody remembers season three when
Teeter decided you know we're in the
middle of a job let's go skinny dipping
um she decides to go skinny dipping
Kobe's like this isn't what we do this
is against protocol uh but okay let's do
it and then we find ourselves in trouble
so it's a very organic thing where
Teeter kind of does what she wants and
Colby's like we shouldn't do this but he
feels like he needs to protect her but
also she brings a little bit of the Wild
Side from him too so I think that's
that's a really genuine situation for
both of them ooh I love that okay now
I'm even more excited for this uh there
are so many spin-offs of Yellowstone I
mean this show is just so wildly popular
how much would you love to see your
character and some of the other
characters on one of these spin-offs
like four sixes perhaps
yeah um there's a there's a lot you know
the the world is expanding uh rapidly
um which I think is just great and it
really speaks to the the audience
engagement
um and the desire for more and you know
Taylor Sheridan who's kind of created
this whole world
um has really just done a great job of
giving every kind of universe its own
unique
um spin to lead all the way up to this
um but yeah you know the opportunity
presents itself
um I think Kobe would love to be able to
you know stay with his friends
um the people that they've been working
with you know it's funny because we also
talk about the characters of the show
but also like us as artists and us as
friends that are friends off of the show
you know when people leave the show
um to go do something else or whatever
like or for like Jefferson white who
plays Jimmy who leaves at the end of
season four to go down to the four sixes
all that that kind of last day of where
he's kind of give everybody a hug and
going like there's not a lot of acting
right like where he's actually going to
Texas so he's really not in Montana he
really isn't in Texas and so for us as
you know actual friends that also is a
hard thing to kind of go through that
transition so uh it's always fun but you
know you always want to just play the
reality of the Universe
um when you have a show like this is so
successful you just want to do the best
that you can to not get in its way
that's a good that's a good way of
putting it I like that now Jefferson did
say he would be in this season right yes
yes Jefferson Jefferson is Jefferson is
in the season
um he doesn't he couldn't just Escape
entirely uh but we're hoping we are all
hoping that there will be some
situations Beyond everybody else's
control that will thrust him back onto
the Yellowstone when that will happen
and what that will look like we are all
also waiting
um you know because we don't it's not
like they call us and like run anything
past us right they send us the script we
look at it we're just kind of shocked
um so it's always fun especially when
the show airs we kind of like to watch
the show with everybody else because
we're always like fragmented sometimes
so uh Jefferson is definitely still on
the show uh he can't just Escape he
still wears the brand so you can't like
leave uh and not have any uh
opportunities to come back
true so you already know this I don't
even have to say this but I'm just
curious the kind of attention you get
you know the fans of Yellowstone they're
thirsty they love all of you what kind
of attention and DMS do you get on
social media
yeah the social media world is
definitely picked up in the last couple
of years
um it's definitely a little bit strange
sometimes especially because you know
you you'll do certain projects and some
people watch them and some people won't
but now no matter where we go
um you know I was we were really shocked
you know when we went to New York I was
doing a film or a TV show in New York uh
in March and I was where's the middle of
Times Square and people are coming up to
you in the elevator and I was like I
didn't even know that people in New York
watched Yellowstone or even here in
California
um and so it was very it's just
fascinating you know they of course they
say some very very wild things you know
because they sometimes they don't
realize that like you're not the
character right so it's funny because
like one like funny story is like one
time I was walking down the street and
somebody was like like they come up to
me like Hey where's your hat and your
boots I'm like bro I'm in the middle of
Los Angeles I don't really I don't
actually own any horses I don't know
what to tell you uh but you know it's
really funny because it's like it just
shows that we're it's very authentic
they're the greatest fan base because
really without them we were not having
any of these conversations but it is
funny because as you're experiencing
this type of stuff you really realize
like dang they they really believe that
all of us and most of us all kind of
grew up and lived in big cities so uh we
really getting to experience this kind
of Slice of Life with those Western
World and uh I think it's great that
we're being embraced the way that we are
I love it like everyone around here at
ET Canada we can't stop talking about it
we're so obsessed so I get it I I do
believe you don't have your own horse
but I can see how fans just want you to
that's hilarious right right right now
aside from Yellowstone uh you are
definitely keeping busy you directed and
co-wrote a short film called the zoo
what can you tell us about that yes uh
it's a passion project of mine that
we're developing into a TV series and
possibly a feature in the years to come
um but yes it was something that you
know as I got older I wanted to be able
to use my platform to tell more African
stories and more of our history
um and so the zoo is about
um Africans that were in the Holocaust I
was actually very dense and very dark
but it was about the Germany's
colonization of Africa and the stories
of what that was in sub-Saharan Africa
um specifically in the Congo region in
Namibia region
um and so we wanted we wrote a story
that was unique to that that was based
off of all true events
um and so that was the first time of it
took about 10 years for us actually even
for me to want to put it out there we
did a lot of research read a lot of
books had to get the rights to certain
books
um and so we did this as kind of a proof
of concept and then it just turned into
an actual film and they're like you
gotta direct this and I was far too
emotional I think to wanting to do that
because it was just I'm so close to the
characters that we created but
nonetheless we have a great team we put
it together
um and I can always send it to you guys
if you want to take a look at it so
we're very very happy
um with how it turned out and we're very
much looking forward to um developing it
into a TV series a limited series um as
well as a potential feature film
that is incredible especially the amount
of time that you put into this seeing
that people want to see more of that and
see it developed is there a way that
your fans can watch that right now
um yeah so it's on the what is it Vimeo
Vimeo I don't know that what's a Vimeo
there's the the I think it's Vimeo
venmo's the one that you sent me money
on
um but if you also want to send me money
you can do that on venmo uh but uh but
yeah you can see it on Vimeo and I think
if you just type in like the zoo
um you'll be able to pop up and I also
can send you guys um a link to it so
that you can watch it as well uh we were
happy we got a lot of great love at the
film festivals
um we won a couple of awards and which
was great um so you know we're excited
about what it what it could be what it's
going to turn into
um you know and so you know we'll just
kind of see so it's all about trying to
use the the platform to promote more of
our history as well so it's kind of it's
a it's a blessing to be able to be a
part of such a successful show of
Yellowstone but then also on the
personal level be able to do kind of
projects and be a part of things that
you probably never would have imagined
you would ever be able to be a part of
but because of the great support that
you're getting you kind of get these
opportunities that I love hearing that
that is that's amazing and then it was
really cool to learn that you have
written a sense of a a wellness book a
self-help book about mastering the mind
how do you master the mind yeah so
mastering your mind came out
um because of everything that's kind of
been going on in the world and you know
it's been hard for a lot of people in a
lot of different countries and we're all
kind of going through some of the same
things
um and I think sometimes as artists we
can be a little bit insulated because
people you know they see us on
television and they think that like
everything is great in life right and
it's not always it's not always like
that was it like not everything that
shimmers as gold or whatever
um and so one of the things that we
wanted to I wanted to do was you know
really give people an opportunity to not
be feel like they have to fall victim
emotionally
um to every single thing that's
happening in the world that they can
kind of be the masters of their own
world the masters of their own mind and
it usually starts there right we think
about things first and then our world
starts to create itself so really
everything is about the difference
between action and intention right if I
if I want to get out of bed I can intend
to get out of bed but my action has to
be to get out of bed so mastering your
mind is really about trying to find
different ways to hold yourself
accountable but then to also not allow
yourself to be get to give power to
other people that are not you that are
not in your situation and you never have
to explain to anybody about why you're
growing
um just grow and grow unapologetically
and just live the the most authentic and
unique you
wow that is such good advice I feel like
that is something that a lot of people
would love to learn how to do uh that's
incredible wow so much to talk to
talking about this is really cool I mean
look excited for Yellowstone I'm excited
to see what happens with the zoo and and
congratulations on everything all right
thank you thank you so much and by the
way if anybody does if they're
interested in getting the Mastery of the
mind they can go to my Instagram and
it's a link in my bio which is just at
denim Richards
um and so it's right there you just
click the link and then it pops up and
it's
um and it's all yours and the proceeds
for the book goes to a organization that
I support called operation Underground
Railroad
um that supports um it's an organization
that is dedicated to eradicating uh
trafficking uh adult and child sex
trafficking like worldwide
um so it's a big organization great
they're doing some phenomenal things in
all the four corners of the earth
um that I partnered with a couple of
years ago so
um just know that it's also going to a
really good cause as well oh my God I'm
so happy you shared that I was just
going to wrap everything up so thanks
for sharing that that's amazing wow